écoutez maintenant me faire rentrer
quelqu'un qui est irakienne voici kenza
kenza bonsoir donc on vous a connu au
départ comme kenza du loft
on savait pas que vous étiez irakienne
votre vrai nom semanal braga ou pas du
tout kenza vous êtes né en irak à bagdad
le 13 novembre 1976 et ça donne une
scène arrive au pouvoir quand vous avez
trois ans alors vous dites quand vous
parlez de saddam hussein oui c'est vrai
c'est un tyran mais sous son règne il ya
eu quand même des avancées
technologiques et industrielles 1 oui
c'est vraiment j'ai vécu la guerre iran
irak qui a duré bien sûr 8 ans tout le
monde le sait et c'est vrai que moi j'ai
vu l'irak fleurir dans les années 80 je
crois que ça a été les années les plus
belles que l'irak a vécu et c'est vrai
que j'ai vu des avances des avancées
technologiques assez importante depuis
que saddam et oreilles mais n'y a pas eu
que ça il a aussi mis en avant
l'éducation qui était quelque chose de
très important dans le pays et il a fait
aussi malgré le fait qu'il soit un
dictateur certes je le confirme
mais il a fait des choses formidables
aussi pour son pays alors vous avez 14
ans dans la guerre du golfe éclate et
leur la nuit du 17 janvier 1991 vous
dormez dans un sommeil profond
votre cartable et préparer pour aller à
l'école et en pleine nuit votre mère
vous traîne dans la cave et j'ai vu mon
père pour la première fois devenir blanc
et devenir non pas un homme formé un
homme qui avait peur et qui savait pas
réellement quoi faire donc c'est avec ma
mère a pris les devants et était ce jour
là beaucoup plus forte que mon père et
c'est vrai que ce côté où je voyais mon
père depuis très longtemps
cet homme orientale qui nous montrait
toujours qu'il était disponible qui
était le l'homme le feu lui l'homme le
plus fort de la famille c'est vrai que
ce 7ème s'est transformé en quelques
secondes en un petit enfant qui avait
été avéré lors de la guerre alors c'est
une nuit qui vous a extrêmement marqué
vous dites aujourd'hui le premier
mercredi du mois à midi quand j'entends
les sirènes à un pari j'ai les nerfs
encore à fleur de peau vous êtes resté
une semaine sans sortir de la brume qui
atomique
japonais avait construit dans votre
immeuble moderne exactement oui dans ces
abris tout le monde était entassé les
gosses il y avait des vieux oui c'était
assez difficile qui avait aucun aucune
comment vous dire on en a pas on n'a
rien préparé y avait pas d'eau potable
aucune condition d'hygiène confortable
avec les enfants commençaient à tomber
malade
moi j'ai vu des des hommages est tombé
rapidement malade il est petit mon père
est tombé très malade
malgré qu'ils soient médecins et que
j'ai rarement vu tomber malade comme
cette fois moi je commençais si je peux
me permettre d'utiliser ce terme j'avais
une diarrhée qui commençait un peu à
être assez suspicieuse donc ma mère une
semaine après à lui a dit à mon père
écoute moi je pars je jeu mais là le
point sur la table le régime j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] moi je la vigne des
enfants coûte
il n'y a pas de prix pour la vigne des
enfants donc je me casse avec mes
enfants il traversera les frontières
avec maintenant c'est ce qu'elle a fait
d'ailleurs vous êtes parti vous êtes
retrouvé dans un camp de l'onu à la
frontière iranienne vous arriver en
france
tout ça vous le racontez dans un bouquin
qui va sortir dans quelques jours vous
reviendrai nous parler du livre mais
gestione ce soir avoir votre témoignage
parce que finalement c'est votre ville
natale qu'on est en train de bombarder
je pense que je sais pas je pense que
personne ne contredira ici pour qu'il
cède est un dictateur
vraiment je suis irakienne en procès
depuis mes 18 ans mais je confirme que
c'est un dictateur bien sûr elle ne
rejoint pas le droit mais ça donne
on a donné toutes les possibilités en 80
ans quand il a démarré la guerre en 90
on lui a donné toutes les possibilités
sur les négociations il a attaqué le
koweit pour là ça fait 12 ans qu'on lui
dit si tu donnes l'épreuve depuis le 21
avril 91 que tu as tout désarmés on lève
l'embargo élire ayant 95 %
c'est pas enfants car c'est l'autre
critère romain vous savez bien ce que
twitter qui a été un inspecteur de l'onu
a vraiment ils étaient en irak pendant
ces fêtes
ainsi si et s'est fait virer il a oublié
simplement dire ici à ses tables en 98
il s'est fait virer et que de 98 à
maintenant quel cap et saddam hussein
qu'est ce que la preuve c'est qu'on a
abordé toutes les solutions en tout cas
possible
on leur a proposé tout et qu'est ce
qu'il a trouvé comme moyen en 98 de
renvoyer les inspecteurs dont scott
ritter donc en 98 il se met hors la loi
les 598 bien sûr cela ne soyez pas
boucher est le seul à répondre déjà par
galanterie
tous les moyens d'endiguer cette guerre
je suis pour la guerre contre saddam et
pour la paix pour le peuple iranien vous
pensez qu'il n'existe pas d'autre moyen
de 2 les a tous essayé on a toutes les
avancées technologiques et avec tous les
renseignements généraux que bush avant
ça en sa possession il n'a pas pu depuis
pas mal de temps en tout cas depuis très
longtemps
débarrassé le l'irak de saddam proposez
quoi je propose quoi c'est pas à moi de
donner des solutions messieurs je suis
désolé moi je suis là si saddam hussein
non mais boucher pas du tout en train d'
assassinat saddam hussein est en train
d'assassiner du repas lors d'un examen
comme la famille là bas
bien sûr j'ai encore de la famille j'ai
lu récemment quelqu'un de la famille ya
à peu près deux semaines
ouais mais on a eu j'ai ressenti
beaucoup de tristesse dans la voix
beaucoup de fatigue
je crois qu'ils en ont vraiment répondre
au téléphone oui j'ai eu un emploi
télévision en français ce jour là et pas
en irak qui a ri parce qu'en fait il m'a
demandé tout de suite mon numéro de
portable
il y a il m'a appelé d'une cabine
téléphonique qui m'a dit écoute je te
rappelle pourquoi pas pourquoi je vais
vous le dire parce qu'en fait il m'a
quand il m'a appelé j'ai commencé un
petit peu lui poser des questions sur la
situation du pays comment est ce qui se
préparait à la guerre et les quelques
mots de français qu'il a pu utiliser son
parle pas parle pas voilà c'est en fait
je crois qu'il ya un mélange de paranoïa
est un mélange de peur je crois que ils
ont l'impression que la plus simple
cabine téléphonique dans la rue et sous
écoute donc vous vous avez grandi dans
le rayon de saddam hussein effectivement
vous n'êtes pas pour saddam hussein mais
vous trouvé dommage que penser des
paralysés de chauffe gilles bombardé
direct non lui tout va bien
je suis content mais à un moment faut
agir mesdames en écraser une mouche avec
un pavé en mai récemment bush a déclaré
qu'il n'avait aucun intérêt à attaquer
l'irak alors vous pouvez m'expliquer
alors qu'elle est au alors
l'installation sombre et intérêts si si
on vous explique si on écoute monsieur
ou si on explique ce que dit ou ce qu'on
nous explique dans les journaux ça
ferait des intérêts pétroliers
si c'est des intérêts pétroliers il a
tout intérêt à lever l'embargo à faire
la paix avec ce dictateur et à faire
immédiatement du commerce
il a tout intérêt c'est son intérêt
immédiat là ils essaient ils ont essayé
depuis le 12 septembre à l'oeil nu de
convaincre l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale que c'était un danger
pour tout le monde
ils n'ont pas réussi parce que les
français ont dit quel que soit le vote
nous mettrons rare il dort on sait
qu'ils ont dit aussi les russes et des
chinois ah bah oui mais merci de
l'association russe assassins de
tchétchènes qui ont un pied dans le sang
et les chinois c'est yen à men etc le
tibet donc on s'est allié avec aline
pour pour se débarrasser d'un adolf
hitler
on a dû on sait bien allier avec staline
qui était pas non plus un enfant de
besoin on est un enfant de coeur est
tout à fait c'est à dire que c'est là
qu'on peut s'allier avec le diable
un certain moment oui mes potes contre
qui là on salit pas contre saddam
la hausse a dit on salit contre bush et
contre les volumes et les gens qui
veulent diriger le monde mais non mais
on fait un métier vous
diriger l'eau commence à diriger le mans
à aucun moment ils volent difficilement
oui d'accord mais c'est parce que je
pense du tout et c'est contre tout cas
une chose très importante qu'il faut
bien comprendre ici la doctrine de
gauche prg et hors active c'est en fait
à la troisième guerre mondiale parce que
au terme de ces screens toute nation qui
est perçu comme étant la menace est peu
dense et la guerre ce qui veut dire que
l'inde peu après qu'elle inclut ce temps
le pakistan peut attaquer note la corée
du sud sur la corée du nord et vice
versa la terre la chine pattaya
thaïlande israël paix avec la palestine
légitime monde
alors où s'arrête tout pour le prix ça
c'est à dire c'est la paix à tout prix
là prêts à tout prix c'est continuer la
dictature de saddam j'ai bien compris ce
qui a été dit et je suis absolument pas
d'accord je tue absolue nous avons vécu
attentionné s'ajuster une chose qu'est
ce que vous pensez de cette manière de
cette manière de que bush entreprend de
vouloir pacifier en fait donc la région
vous pensez pas que ça ressemble plus à
une colonisation et que demain il va
s'attaquer aussi à la jordanie et va
s'attaquer aussi à l'arabie saoudite
il va s'attaquer aussi aux autres pays
qui l'entourent vous avez l'impression
que c'est une joueuse aussi une méthode
pour pour coloniser lorient et pour
monopoliser le riz en plus je ne sais
pas ça écoutez on a l'expérience
arrêtez de me prendre des hypothèses
prônée par le kosovo au kosovo est ce
qu'ils sont restés qu'ils ont occupée
non ils ont donné le mandat à la
communauté internationale pour que
monsieur kouchner essaye de remettre des
éléments de démocratie est ce que quand
ils ont fait la guerre en 91
ils sont restés au koweit et ils ont
essayé de développer leur empire au
koweit on leur reproche suffisamment ils
n'ont même pas donner des éléments pour
essayer de faire avancer la démocratie
est ce que est ce que toi les enquêteurs
disposaient que va devenir l'irak après
parce que gbagbo dit aujourd'hui on n'a
aucune réponse mais le rapport à la
taille
et rappelez vous le savez qu'ici l'irak
et démocratique comme il ya 60% de
chiites
l'irak doit être un pays site qui va
donc être intégré en saxe et la neige
comme lire comme l'iran parce que ce
qu'on connaît des discussions qui ont
lieu à londres qui a eu lieu à
washington avaient tous les exilés ils
sont 4 millions comme vous il ya 4
millions de personnes qui ont fui le
pays nous et des démocrates et ils
essayent de construire un autre pays
possible ça soit possible de discuter
car de bien sûr ex directeur éric un
manque avec les américains et la
communauté internationale avec les
anglais les australiens m le dire merci
aux américains c'est là après tout bien
sûr comme je leur dis merci pour avoir
libéré la pénombre l'apprendront des
deux titulaires vous c'est ça ab je
crois que c'est pire parce qu'une claire
a déjà existé
alors que saddam hussein ces cinquante
ans après claire de tolérer et qu'on
supporte ce qui s'est passé ce qui est
en train de se passer par rapport au
peuple irakien est une abomination vu le
souvenir chemin de la période ben ali
juste avec ça je veux dire une chose je
crois que si aujourd'hui vous demandez
aux irakiens s'il préfère demain à voir
les américains sur leur sol ou livre
encore 20 30 40 ans avec sa dame qui est
un dictateur je peux vous assuré je peux
vous assurer qu'il vivra encore avec sa
dalle simplement un tout qui nous a tous
plus beaux atouts des alliés des royaux
renaud girard le figaro regardez ce
qu'ils disent
les légendes de bagdad quand on lui
demande s'il n'a pas peur il répond avec
un grand sourire il y a une semaine je
ne vous aurais jamais parlé comme ça
mais depuis hier j'ai senti que la peur
mme avaient soudainement quitté
je me sens comme libéré d'un immense
pardo enfin pouvoir dire ce qu'on veut
dans leur immense majorité les irakiens
bol un changement de régime
ils souhaitent que leur pays soit placé
sous la protection des américains et des
anglais ils haïssent la position de la
france de l'allemagne et de la russie
bush le père à libérer le koweït bouche
le fils va libérer l'irak la rue rachid
la plus vieille de bagdad devra un jour
porté son nom et ça continue tous les
gens alors qu'en penses-tu c'est pour
quand on en a assez d'attendre et
celui-là saddam hussein en tant que
nation
d'accord si on prend parmi la population
qu'elle gardait ses tatouages il tout ne
s'est pas dû c'est l'humain de gao et le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que ce
journaliste est tout à fait honnête par
tous les conduits qui l'a coupée
simplement il ya une semaine personne
n'y parlait maintenant tout le monde va
lui parler en lui disant mais pourvu
qu'ils arrivent vite et qui nous libère
de 30 ans de dictature
on n'a jamais demandé aux américains de
venir nous libérer de quoi que ce soit
et maintenant